oh et paris mais qui me suit et
émerveillés par les progrès réalisés en
4 1 par valmont cmh est ce que si on
pouvait ce qu'a mis la tête on verrait
comment les neurones se sont connectés
son fils que maintenant lire des mots en
cuisine il est devenu un chef d'une
redoutable efficacité
c'est comme ça on est en train de voir
émerger le rêve allemand
l' approche développée par deux
québécoises permet aujourd'hui avalement
de mieux communiquer se fait en sorte
qu' il est de plus en plus capables de
parler pour lui même d'arriver à dire ce
qu'il veut c'est glousser fois il y a
quatre ans qu'il suit disait que son
fils était autiste non verbale son
vocabulaire se limite encore une dizaine
de mots mais aujourd'hui valmont réussi
à se faire entendre et c'est mon dieu ma
vie est trop belle c'est plus concret
lors de notre dernière rencontre en 2017
valmont commençait à peine à reconnaître
certaines sensations comme la fatigue ou
la fin aujourd'hui c'est lui qui
planifie son menu du jour vous allez
voir ce qu'ils veulent ce soir
l'anc est il le veut ne porte pas dans
sa voie avec le fromage donc ce soir
c'est ce que je sais déjà planifié
wallon a même trouvé une façon de
commander des repas au restaurant il ya
découvert le poulet saint-hubert
ébéniste à l'école ils savaient pas
comment nous et dont il a apporté un
jour de papier pour nous montrer
il ya collé sur l'armoire il vient il
nous montre comment moi si c'est lui ou
l'autre il connaît la différence entre
les deux c'est extraordinaire
l'immeuble de probablement de mots le 2
mai il mal pas de trucs par exemple pour
se faire comprendre sans merci avec la
communication ce qu'on voit arriver
c'est la flexibilité c'est la
planification la résolution problème
ça fait plus que baisser lens était je
crois je pense que ça apporte du 4runner
tout simplement exister un de ne pas
savoir comment demander
sadr est incroyablement 10 il est là le
capam identifié capable de lire et voir
les solutions aussi c'est magique
non mais la sauce kim thuy répète
souvent que son fils prend maintenant le
contrôle de la cuisine
j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous faire le
gâteau aux bananes
sauf que maintenant et ici quelques
bananes ne sont pas prêtes pour le
gâteau banal donc répondre gâteau avant
se dit qu'ils étaient non verbale mais
maintenant il est verbale dans le sens
où utilisent il ne peut plus de bon il
ya peut-être dix mots dans son
vocabulaire mais utilise le bon mot au
bon moment c'est à dire illustration
souvent ici pour manger c'est sa place
la plus confortable et avant
s'il n'y avait pas cette sauce va se
lever il va me demander de l'aider mais
physiquement alors que maintenant que ça
soit comme cet envy celle des gens d'en
face c'est parfait on peut pas prédire
qui va faire un grand orateur mais qui a
au moins le bagage les mots pour
exprimer ses besoins pour toute sa vie
c'est énorme
on a crevé clp j'ai testé pour voir
s'ils comprenaient vraiment ce que les
ces symboles représentent
il sait maintenant que la langue écrite
représente un objet je dirais que c'est
un travail de longue haleine
c'est un apprentissage d'un langage en
2017 qui me suit nous expliquer comment
le cerveau de valmont fonctionner de
façon statique comme un enchaînement de
diapositives
on dit souvent que les outils sont
rigides mais c'est son projet de sens
tactique parce qu'ils prennent des
images et non pas un film donc pour eux
et passe même valmont et passe devant
il y apprit une image la tangerine est à
droite de la tasse mais là si je déplace
et que la tangerine et si les événements
d'un moment la tangerine ça et prend du
temps parce qu'il doit reprendre un
autre photo me dire ou es la tangerine
plaît il faut qu'ils décollent mais avec
les années de travail les images dans la
tête de valmont s'enchaînent beaucoup
plus facilement et la maintenance
atteinte à capable de se déplacer avec
nous je sais c'est difficile
imaginez qu'une peine bouge pas que les
statuts mais pour les personnes autistes
très souvent ces seuls
la difficulté c'est d'avoir ce mouvement
là dans mon psy réflexion dans sa pensée
dans ce soit dans son interprétation de
la réalité du quotidien autour de
souvent les gens pensent qu'un
diagnostic d'autisme c'est une fin en
soi au début beaucoup j'étais harrison
est elle-même autistes avec lise saint
charles
ce qu'elle enseigne avalement c'est une
façon de mieux vivre avec sa condition
si le même parcours que moi j'ai fait
mais je suis parti d'un peu plus avancée
que lui c'est tout c'est que c'est la
même chose et ça permet d'avoir un accès
plus intéressant je voudrais qualité de
vives entre et pour soi et pour les
jeunes qui sont autour de nous
avec le temps le travail permet à
valmont d'avoir une meilleure qualité de
vie à la maison et une plus grande
autonomie à l'extérieur quand il sort
prend démarche par exemple alors avec la
marche
au début je pense qu'il ne voyait que un
boom on est pauvre non il marchait
toujours derrière moi puis de temps en
temps il y avait besoin de toucher mon
bras pour savoir que je suis encore là
et ils se mesuraient par rapport à moi
et là on a travaillé en ce moment avec
saccades et on le fait marcher vraiment
à ma gauche et apparemment sallèles
beaucoup à absorber ce qui se passe au
taux au niveau visuel mais après
quelques semaines pour seulement qu'il a
vu mais je pense qu'il ya vu plus que
juste mon bureau mon épaule il n'a plus
besoin de toucher mon bras est
aujourd'hui peut marcher à gauche à
droite devant ça ne le dérange plus mais
je vois qu'ils voient maintenant comme
on dit le plus beau mot pour deux mois
que je n'ai pas avant c'est faux à
valmont démontre qu'il a la capacité de
réaliser encore plus de progrès de lire
encore plus de mots de mieux communiquer
ses besoins ses intentions on espère
aussi qu'ils vont pouvoir avoir une
suite
au-delà de 21 ans car après 21 ans c'est
la famille qui doit prendre en charge
tout le soutien dont un autiste a besoin
c'est comme si on disait
avec à 21 heures vous avez plus
d'insuline cela me choque les gens
exactement la même chose on répété on
répète qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour faire
le travail et la tradition d'autistes la
valmont avait droit à 21 ans mais les
clients document 75 ans on continue on
n'arrête pas donc je suis en train de
planifier après 21 ans pour seulement
pour valmont mais j'espère pouvoir le
faire pour ses 42 places avec qui il a
grandi